the first ever jigsaw puzzle
international convention is here in las
vegas
family-friendly and it's going to be a
fundraiser for kids with special needs
and as if that weren't enough they're
going to help break a world record job
on our mary jane valeeza live at the las
vegas convention center it's puzzling
but there is an easy way to figure it
all out help us out mary jane
you guys have all the great puzzle puns
early this morning and i'm just so
excited because this is the first of its
kind not only in las vegas but ever and
i'm joined bright and early this morning
with alex wakney who is the founder of
the jigsaw puzzle convention here in las
vegas and alex thank you so much for
joining us brian early we're at the
puzzle store i mean we have so many
puzzles around us tell us you know what
this is all about
so these puzzles are extremely unique
because you can't find them here in the
united states you cannot obviously order
them online but
what happens is with the cost of
shipping it doubles the price and people
usually don't buy these so we have
brands like educablojas from spain
grafica from france like they have
extremely nice images
we have puzzles coming from turkey and
romania and poland like a truffle
what's unique here is that every single
box you see here
we only have one piece of each so every
image you see if you like something
you're going to have to take it right
away because we don't have two identical
boxes we just got
one image of each puzzle and brought in
a few pallets of these so
and you know what is it that you would
like people to know when they when they
come here and they take away from the
puzzle store i mean this isn't only just
about putting puzzles together but they
can learn a little bit of education too
well absolutely but
the first and foremost what's
jigsaw puzzles is more of a therapy for
a lot of people you have for example
people that went through cancer and they
went through chemotherapy and they can't
move and they're debilitated and doing
jigsaw puzzles helped them
to relax to go through therapy
and to really just keep things together
to get through
very difficult times in their lives
that's perfect and of course if you want
to come down and check it out tickets
are still on sale if you'd like to come
down for this weekend this is a
three-day event there's so much to see
and do it is a family-friendly event so
please come down and check it out it's
also a great way to support our local
community here in las vegas with that
fundraising donation area when it comes
down to the puzzle exchange reporting
live mary jane vallieza live local now